and finally new rule now that polls show
that the public finds the news media
less trustworthy then Donald Trump they
have to fight to get their reputation
back and there are encouraging signs
that that fight has been joined the New
York Times no longer shied away from
saying Trump lies on the front page
also sometimes [ __ ] and [ __ ] on the
front page which is awesome Scott Pelley
at CBS whoo I do not like I do not made
me like him one night when he started
his broadcast like this it has been a
busy day for presidential statements
divorced from reality
Chuck Todd had this moment with
Kellyanne Conway for the five packs the
other which is not true
look alternative facts are not facts
they're falsehood and take a look at
George Stephanopoulos kickin little
Stephen Miller's balls up into his chest
cavity your that is zero evidence that
the president's claimed that he would
have one of general the popular vote but
if three to five million illegal
immigrants hadn't voted zero evidence
for either one of those claims well see
it's Frank Sinatra's joy noting if you
die we're gonna need a lot more of it we
are Trump has the White House
he's got Congress he's got a crazy loyal
fan base what do we have put the hatch
but also people under them you know
there is something there is something
about getting in the street that makes a
powerful statement that we care that
we're not afraid and that we feel so
strongly we're willing to use a porta
potti
we're liberals damn it we're tanned
rested and gluten free and we are the
type of people who will throw a trash
can through a Starbucks window and then
climb through and say you know while
we're here could I get a double mocha
song alright so we got the streets we
still got the courts but judges die and
if only Republicans are in power to
replace them that could be bad which
leaves the press the free press that is
enshrined in our Constitution but for
the press to be effective these numbers
have to change can you imagine how this
must make a reporter feel to be losing a
truthfulness contest to Donald Trump
it's like losing a rap battle to Mitt
Romney
now you can be mad at me for giving a
platform to Milo but Donald Trump is the
apotheosis of the old right and the
media gave him the biggest platform ever
they covered every Trump rally like we
put a game show host on the moon they
made him look like he was president
before he was even during the primaries
Trump got three times the coverage of
the entire rest of the field
although Marco Rubio was able to break
through one week because he gave a very
important speech about how Trump had a
small [ __ ] and you know what they say
about men with small hands
[Applause]
other than that it was prompt Trump
Trump he got over twice as much coverage
as Hillary and Bernie combined because
their policy people not tiny [ __ ] people
and now with so much happening all at
once we really need our news sources to
war in but the second half of the
nightly news still looks like this from
time to time
everyone needs a hug tonight 78 year-old
Shirley Webb deadlifting 225 pounds at
her gym near st. Louis are unicorns will
the primping to pampering the pooches
now up for top dog what is your goat's
name Wow and what's your name farm all
that special I by bow bow okay guys to
take of the Republic you've got to get
serious again you have to win your
respect back
so Trump can't say the people don't
believe you you're a joke look at what
was on Time magazine's website last week
these dads doing ballet with their
daughters is the only thing you need to
watch today no that's the definition of
what I don't need
henry luce must be spinning in his grave
or his time would put it you would
believe what our founder is doing now
the news media lost trust because they
became eyeball chasing clickbait ors who
bumped the story about climate change
for the one about grizzly bears in the
jacuzzi you know there is an answer to
this when TV started there was an
understanding between the folks who
owned the airwaves the American people
and the folks who made TV the Jews and
that understanding was that the news
wasn't supposed to make money it was
something the corporation's gave us as a
public service
CBS News is 3% of CBS's revenue CNN 4%
of Time Warner's ABC and NBC News are
only one and a half percent of Disney
and Comcast guys take one for the team
it's not that much it'll pay off in the
long run you know why because the best
customers are alive maybe yes maybe
people will even surprise you they may
they might actually prefer not being
treated like children people tell me
every day how much they appreciate vice
news and a new season of ice starts in a
couple of net